um
i uh uh just at the top wanted to uh
make a couple of points about uh that
kind of context on uh our current
economic situation uh and then happy to
take questions that you have um so four
quick points uh first is the context on
our economic recovery
we've learned based on data that we've
received over the last several days
that in 2021 our economy experienced the
largest single drop
in the unemployment rate on record in
the history of the country down to 3.9
percent
the most jobs created in any year on
record 6.4 million
the strongest economic growth of any
year
in nearly four decades
coming in between 5.6 5 and 6
over the course of 2021 in all uh
likelihood
and real household income
that is taking an account of price
increases increased uh in 2021 um so
just
to repeat that context the largest
decline in unemployment the most jobs
created
and the strongest economic growth in
nearly 40 years
the second point is we got december
price data today
and i would note that we saw a
welcome
deceleration
in the rate of price increases
in a number of respects uh in the
headline uh price increased data we saw
a a decline month to month to 0.5
percent down from 0.8 percent in the
month before uh it's still too high but
a moving in the right direction
as i i think i say every time here and
if i don't i uh it's a mistake we never
index too heavily on any individual one
month of data in any direction uh but i
would note that we saw in prices from
november to december a decline
in the rate of growth of
the prices for food at home which is a
technical way of saying food that people
buy in the grocery store
and we saw a drop in the price of energy
both at the gas pump but also natural
gas and winter
heating
costs
um
and uh many of you focused on the annual
seven percent uh uh rate um if we are
trying to look at uh where we are headed
the month-to-month changes are more
instructive uh and most independent
forecasters uh continue to project that
we will see moderation in price
increases uh over the course of
2022. a third point is the global
context for this data both on prices and
on economic uh growth writ large what
we're seeing right now is these price
increases are a global phenomenon
and that reflects the nature of the
global challenge of coming through
a
pandemic crisis and a pandemic affected
recovery um
over the past six months price increases
in the united states and europe have uh
have basically run neck and neck
in december the eu saw its highest
recorded inflation in
on record
germany saw its highest inflation in
december
since reunification
and so
while there are differences uh but
country by country this is a global
phenomenon and driven by these global
issues which comes to the fourth point
which is uh given the unique strength of
the united states economic recovery
overall uh growth as well as the labor
market
we are well positioned to attack the
challenges of prices and costs head-on
and that's exactly what the president
and this administration are doing um and
it's his principal focus when it comes
to the economy
as he laid out on friday
his approach to attacking prices and
costs are grounded
in the in the the premise that the right
way to do this is to build on the
economic successes that we have seen not
to abandon them
and that really means
with respect to what we the pre in the
administration and congress can do is to
focus on how we can expand the
productive capacity economy how we can
make sure that our economy can produce
more goods and services more cheaply and
easily
across the country get more people uh
working
and
get to the strong sustainable growth
that we are beginning to see
and if we can
address these present challenges we'll
hopefully see going forward
the president's outlined a very specific
three-part plan to do that around
unsticking supply chains protecting
consumers and promoting competition
and trying to actually reduce directly
some of the most significant costs that
americans families face and obviously
key elements of the buildback better uh
framework go directly um at that issue
um and so i'm happy to talk about the
policy details uh behind that plan
in general but i just think just to
summarize
we have uh historically strong economic
growth and labor market outcomes uh we
have saw some welcome deceleration but
price increases that are still too high
uh decidedly a global phenomenon
happening everywhere but we um in the
united states are uniquely well
positioned that against uh that
challenge and that's uh that's the
president's focus
brian thanks for coming today the um the
white house and other economists last
spring
and fall were talking about inflation
being transitory and i think at least
the expectation when we were talking
about it last spring was that it was
going to be well taken care of by now
what did you get wrong what did
economist writ large get wrong and how
should americans why should americans be
confident when you say prices are going
to get better later this year
so
i think that if we look at the situation
earlier in the year um
a number of projections and forecasts
have come out differently than we
anticipated um uh if you if you look at
employment for example uh virtually
nobody was projecting that we would see
unemployment fall as quickly um as it as
it has um and get to 3.9 percent by the
end of this year that's four years
faster than the median forecast
um and so i think we've seen a number of
un um unanticipated uh um outcomes when
it comes to uh prices what we have what
we have said consistently focus
consistently is that um this is a global
phenomenon it is connected to the
pandemic um and the issues that that has
uh raised certainly the supply chain
challenges that have um evolved over the
course of time uh through the delta
variant and over the course of the fall
um have been issues that we've had to go
and tackle uh head on
but i think that um the uh nomenclature
aside we uh find ourselves in a position
now where we're looking forward and and
uh and
most uh forecasters are projecting that
the price increases will moderate our
focus here
is looking at what are the concrete
practical steps that we can take to try
to help ensure that outcome and try to
help
accelerate relief where we can where we
appropriately can so when it comes to
something like the supply chain
challenges um those
manifested more significantly than
people were anticipating over the course
of the summer and early fall
both because of uh coveted factors but
also buying behavior of major retailers
and major freight movers and so we went
into action over the course of the fall
to try to help
address those issues and the the
bottlenecking we were seeing at ports
made very significant progress on that
40 decline in the amount of time that a
a container is sitting at the dock and
at the same time we still have work to
do on that front which is why even this
month we're going to take additional
steps uh with ports across the country
to set up inland locations to move uh
products and
impose new fees on empty containers that
are sitting idle uh at our ports so um
so we're gonna we're gonna stay at that
and other issues and we believe that
that's the best way that we can again
help to expand the economy's capacity to
uh to deliver goods and services to the
american people the supply chain then
essentially that is the reason for the
the incorrect forecast
10 months ago
but i i think that we are our focus now
is on why assessing where we are and
trying to address the issues in front of
us in an effort to try to uh accelerate
uh the the course uh the course of the
recovery uh as i said there's lots of
this has been a unique year uh on a lot
of accounts um and uh and so we find
ourselves in a uniquely strong economic
position on a number of counts and we've
got price increases that uh that we need
to we need to tackle and that's our
focus thank you jen and thank you brian
for being here i have a question on on
some of the practical matters that
you've talked about are you taking any
steps to help people afford food despite
the figure that you mentioned that month
to month the prices have gone down my
colleagues are reporting about how
people
are finding shortages on the shelves how
the stuff that is there is more
expensive
is there anything you can do to help
families pay for that food
well i would say um
a number of things one is um when the
president came into office he
prioritized early passing the american
rescue plan
the american rescue plan has historic
investments in actually
addressing food insecurity for people
who couldn't
afford
uh food as a result we saw hunger in the
united states decline in uh in in 2021
it also included a the uh the child tax
credit uh another resource that went
directly that are going uh directly to
families um to help address the you know
typical costs that they face on a
monthly basis um and as a result we saw
um child poverty fall by 35 to 40
percent uh in america over the course of
2021. um and uh uh and uh we saw as i
mentioned we saw some welcome
deceleration in the increase uh in in
the cost of food
this month and we're going to keep
focused on those uh
ways that we can address the typical
pocketbook issues that the american
people face and this is one of the
issues
why the core economic logic behind the
president's behind the buildback better
plan is important in this context
because
for
working americans who are benef who are
benefiting from a strong labor market
and more job opportunities but also
struggling with costs not only of food
but costs of a child care or the cost of
health care
the components of the bill back better
plan would directly address those issues
by putting
by providing a tax cut
to uh to families directly in their
pocketbook and then reducing other of
their most salient costs so for a lot of
the families that you're talking about
if they you know only had to pay seven
percent of their income in child care
that would free up um a lot of resources
to invest in uh in other monthly needs
so i'm sure that passing and
separate from what you have already done
the measures you mentioned is there
anything new you can do
to help the food situation well i would
say first what we have done is historic
and has made a big difference number two
our our central economic legislative
priority is getting uh those elements of
bill back better in place and and part
of the urgency of that is to address
precisely uh the challenges that you are
identifying uh so um and beyond that uh
we are looking at ways that we can
unstick elements of the supply chain
that may be getting in the way of for
example physical product uh getting uh
to market
and certainly we have seen uh we have
seen over the course of this fall we've
seen concerns about
product shortages in particular
categories and otherwise
what we've seen overall if you look at
retail inventories including grocery
store inventories they're actually
higher now than they were pre-pandemics
so in a pretty healthy place
but that doesn't mean that there's
logistical challenges at the bottlenecks
that that may be localized um and to the
degree that we can work with private
sector companies um and help you know um
ease the challenges in their private
sector supply chain certainly we will uh
we'll remain open to doing that
one question on the global challenge
since you mentioned it the president
mentioned it today can you talk about
how much you believe china's latest
round of lockdowns and its zero
case doctrine is having an impact on
inflation since obviously it's impacting
the global manufacturing and has the
administration had any conversations
with china about
the factory workers about the lockdowns
yeah
so there's no question that um the
global nature of the pandemic
affects global supply chains and has
affect affected the flow of goods
across across economies
one of the things that we did earlier
this fall was actually set up what we
call an early warning system working
with a number of our american companies
that rely on
sourcing input components or products
from
southeast asian countries
to identify where there might be
covet outbreaks in those countries
and work with the state department and
usaid and the cdc on the ground in those
countries to do what we can to actually
help to stabilize the situation and
reduce the uh potential impact of a
shutdown or a lockdown or otherwise with
respect to china specifically um uh and
the and the and the current uh moment
we're monitoring it very closely as we
assess
uh the issue today um the lockdowns are
most likely to have the iso effect
isolated in china because the the
production facilities in those
geographies are principally suppliers to
the chinese market um but the situation
is fluid and ongoing and something that
we're monitoring in real time and
working uh across the interagency
including the state department and the
cdc to try to keep a handle on
brian respecting that you said that
prices are expected to moderate in the
months ahead americans right now at the
start of 2022 are setting their budgets
trying to figure out how much things are
going to cost them for themselves and
for their families how much longer
should americans expect that they'll be
paying these inflated prices
so what i what what i can say is that in
the context of a strong economy most uh
independent forecasters expect these
prices to moderate over the course of
2022 and that's consistent with uh uh
the administration's view uh and
you have a president and administration
that's waking up every day
and think about the practical actions we
can take to try to help accelerate that
protecting unsticking supply chains
protecting consumers making sure that
consumers aren't being taken advantage
of in a moment of
uncertainty that means by the end of 22
it's moderated or we're kind of back to
where we were before this by those
projections
well if you look at if you look at the
the the uh the projections by
independent forecasters then you see
moderation over the course of 22 and you
get back to
you you get back to
levels that are are closer to pre uh pre
uh pre-pen that normal um but uh but i
think that you know in the in the in the
short term in the media term
i think there will focus on the
practical steps that we can take um
folks working with congress uh
encouraging congress to take practical
steps that would have real concrete
impact for those families uh in their
lives right now um and delivering in in
practical concrete ways and and i i
think that as we have seen uh with what
we were able to get done in 2021 to
deliver that type of relief directly to
families that can make all the
difference
and that can really help to bridge this
gap
for uh families
and also help to get more people to work
that we continue to face real challenges
where parents
and other caregivers in this economy
want to get back to work but are held
back because of the cost of actually
finding a quality way to take care of a
kid or take care of
an elderly parent that's compounded by
the pandemic and
us acting now to help address those
costs for families would not only
provide some peace of mind to those
families
you know if every american family
with kids knew they weren't going to pay
more than seven percent of their income
in child care that would be a big weight
off their shoulders it'd also be a big
uh benefit to the labor market by
allowing more people to work as
productively as they as they choose to
hi thank you you mentioned the port uh
measures you're taking setting up these
awesome site areas can you talk a little
bit more about that in the developees
they've had that on hold for weeks at
port of long beach and part of la are
you talking about imposing a 12 fee and
other ports in other words can you
give a little more detail what you're
talking about sure um uh uh sure we're
gonna go a little deep on ports but this
is exciting for me
no no it's good i'm i'm thrilled
so
so uh so
the um uh the first issue of the inland
ports and the idea here is relatively
simple which is uh if if you're having
to offload all of the containers at one
location it creates a bottleneck it
means fewer things moving through if you
can push those push that that product
out to
facilities inland then you can increase
the throughput we've taken steps at the
port of savannah to open multiple ports
and we've seen real progress there uh
reduction in the uh the backlog coming
into the port of savannah quite
noticeably so we're going to take action
at the port of oakland
finalizing inland port opportunities
there basically running the same play
there as well and we're working through
the national port associations to
basically work with any port that that
sees that as an opportunity to try to
deploy that and we have money that we
have been able to deploy
associated with the president's
infrastructure legislation to try to
help move that as quickly as possible on
the dwell uh fees there's the issue
around the
fees on impla on on import containers
that they have
identified and said they're willing to
impose
just the threat of doing that
was actually quite effective at getting
the ocean carriers to move on their own
and provide incentives carrots and
sticks to move that through um now this
month they're focused on
a fee on export containers basically the
empty containers that are sitting idle
that need to be moved off and shipped
off in order to create more space
and they are announced the that they
will impose those fees by the end of the
month um but as you know um part of the
announcement of those fees is to give
everybody an opportunity to figure out
is there a more efficient way to solve
this than the imposition of those fees
but that's where things stand
forgive me uh both you and jen for
asking about the fed on december
december
you said
you said that the president would making
joints in the coming days on the first
he said that part of the reason to make
those picks was that people could quote
face squarely ahead on the economic
challenges that we face the governors
can so at the time we're talking about
imminent picks that would help the
central bank with who the president is
now banking on to help fight inflation
uh see around the corners in a direct
dress crisis six weeks later we don't
have pigs so i guess my question is
what's the hold up what changed and do
you think that that six-week delay is
having an impact and you're relying on
the fed to be able to help curb
inflation and they don't have a full
pitch
so in your last question no i don't
think it's it's having an impact i think
that the most immediate
issue um on that score is that um the
president's two nominees to be the chair
and the vice chair of the fed are now up
in in front of the senate uh one had
their uh his uh uh confirmation hearing
yesterday the other will have her
confirmation hearing tomorrow um and
senate moving expeditiously to confirm
uh both of those nominees uh is
important
and we are grateful to uh the uh the
leadership the committee leadership of
chairman brown uh and others in the
senate for moving quickly and that is
important um at the same time uh we are
working closely with congressional
leadership to
finalize those
those additional
nominees
and are confident that we can
move them on a schedule that will mean
that
they will be in place uh uh at um at the
appropriate cadence um so
i don't have any news for you today
about that personal announcement but uh
ball game when you're making these
considerations in terms of considering
particular candidates one against the
other or is it part of a range of
possibilities
so
i think the president laid out his
thinking relatively in a sort of
relatively detailed way in the context
of announcing uh
chairman powell and uh and and governor
brainerd for the positions that he's
nominated them to um and i think that
that basic approach extends to the other
um uh chairs as well so obviously um
um expertise independent judgment
and
you know proximity to the range of
issues that the fed is facing
obviously central among them is that is
charting a course of monetary policy
that sustains the strength of recovery
and achieves the dual mandate while
making sure that prices are not
entrenched
but also facility with other you know um
front and center issues like financial
regulation and
uh and the the
uh the financial threats associated with
climate
and then we'll have change wrap it up
you imagine that you expect persons to
moderate over the course of the year but
how worried are you that consumers and
businesses are starting to expect
inflation it's here to stay and will act
accordingly especially as many workers
aren't feeling any increase in wages due
to the increase in prices
so it's a concern and it's why you heard
the president on friday reinforce that
that the
fed
should and needs to have the
independence to act to make sure that
prices don't become
entrenched i would say that if you look
at
the market uh you don't see
you haven't seen a noticeable move in
long-term inflation expectations uh
as as of recently and uh and so it's uh
it's
it's a concern but it's also part of why
we think that acting uh in the way that
we've laid out um uh and respecting the
independence of the of the fed is uh is
the right approach um and i think that
for you know typical people who are uh
who are working uh and thinking about
their their household budgets
for many of them uh they've never seen a
labor market that offers as many job
opportunities uh uh as as they have
right now
um for people in the bottom 40 of the
income distribution wage increases um
are
up at historic levels which creates uh
new opportunities and for many people uh
they are taking this opportunity to
start new businesses and innovate we've
seen the um uh the rate of new
applications for small businesses up
increased by 30 percent um and that's
that's an opportunity for those those
people and the people that they will
employ but also a real driver of
innovation um and a signal of the health
and the kind of economy and economic
growth that we can
drive if we
if we keep at this
and the last thing i would say is that
for uh for those typical folks sitting
around the kitchen table thinking about
this coming year um
the the the largest single costs that
families face
are
child care the cost of a home
um and
we have concrete practical
straightforward ways to deliver relief
on those costs
and to do so in a way that wouldn't add
to aggregate demand wouldn't create an
inflation
concern would be fully paid for across
time and in fact the principal long-term
economic impact would be to expand our
economy's productive capacity by getting
more people into the workforce so um so
that's why you know our our focus and
our work on buildback better continues
and
i guess we will leave it there oh no we
have one more okay
with the white house support adding the
work requirement like senator manchin as
discussed to the child tax credit as
part of the package
so i think the president has spoken the
importance of the child tax credit and
uh his views um
uh on that topic i would say that if you
look at the
the the child tax credit itself
um
97
of the recipients of the child tax
credit um are working
uh and among the remaining three percent
uh the majority are grandparents
or people with disabilities
so i think that you have a tool that is
delivering relief to working families
right now
and in fact what we've seen over the
course of 2021
is that um as that as that tax cut was
delivered to families we actually saw
labor force participation and the
employment to population ratio increase
um uh meaning that we saw more people uh
get uh into the workforce um and that's
consistent with
evidence uh historically and in other
countries where they have similar child
allowances where you've seen no evidence
of a negative impact on
on labor force participation and in some
cases a positive impact because it frees
people up
to work more so certainly the president
is focused on how to get more people
working and make sure that
the people have opportunities in this
labor market and the child tax credit um
is uh is actually a very well designed
tool to do that
at a minimum the white house doesn't
think it's necessary or it's redundant
or as as part of
as part of the package yeah certainly
the the the child tax credit uh is a um
operates in a way that uh goes to
working families
um and does not create any disincentive
uh for people to work and if anything
would help more families and more people
uh get into the labor market all right
thank you very much
all
right
last one raquel on his way out thank you
so much brian what do you make of
statements that the pandemic will not be
the number one public enemy for the
global economy this year but would be
inflation and how central banks around
the world
will
could be the number one enemy of the
global economy how central banks respond
to inflation and inflation
well what i'd say that is they're very
they're they're interlinked um and that
uh that is um
that's a
has been true and has been a feature of
our economy and our economic recovery uh
for the last uh for the last year and a
half to uh
to the first question
that the
more effective we are as a global
community as a united states and as a
global community at working to
contain this pandemic and under control
reduce the
impact uh on people
and on individual health but also on
economic operations and supply chains
and otherwise the more
quickly we can normalize um supply
chains and address um the price
increases which are decidedly a global
phenomenon so um so i i don't think that
um
i don't think it's an either or um i
think that there is an urgent and
compelling priority to um address uh the
uh the coba pandemic globally which is
why you see this administration and the
president acting um uh across the the
board um from vaccines to the other uh
support that we're providing globally um
and that the more effective we are at
doing that the more runway will provide
for the global economy to grow while
mitigating price increases all right
thank you brian d thank you
okay um i have nothing at the top i'm
mindful of the time um and i will
jump around to people who have not yet
gotten questions but i will start uh
with alex if you want to kick us up um i
have three questions uh first on
inflation um
you know brian talked a lot about
needing to address snares in the supply
chain but you all have taken quite a few
of those steps and we're still seeing
high inflation shortages on shelves so
is this an issue that shows the um
sort of limitations of the presidency
and the executive branch is this an
issue that the president simply can't
solve
i think what it shows and you heard
brian talk about this a bit is that it's
a multi-prong challenge and he talked
about obviously the steps we're taking
to address supply chain challenges and
there's no question those have been
impacted by the pandemic it's all have
also been impacted by a huge increase of
demand and retail purchases online that
we saw across the course of the fall so
that is one challenge that we've been
attacking uh head-on uh we also know
that there are specific industries like
the auto industry that accounts for
about one-third of what we're seeing in
terms of inflationary increases in price
increases and if you look at the
purchases of cars one of the biggest
issues there is is chips and the lack of
manufacturing uh capacity here in the
united states of course that's been
impacted by a range of issues including
the pandemic but one of the things that
we have been advocating for and pushing
for is for congress to move forward in
the comp and taking steps to support and
boost bolster our competitiveness here
uh that includes over 50 billion dollars
in funding for chips manufacturing uh i
would also say that uh you know that
would also help ensure that
manufacturing in the future is the
capacity increased here at home so we're
less dependent on the global supply
chain around the world so i think what
it speaks to alex a good question is uh
the multi-pronged components that impact
uh the supply chain that impact price
increases that people have seen the
american public has seen across the
country do you have an
update on how the iran talks are going
over the jcpoa sure the administration
be satisfied with
how they're going so i know there's been
a lot going on uh this has certainly
been been happening um
right now uh what's happening is uh on
monday um uh january 3rd uh the eighth
round of negotiations uh commenced uh in
vienna um and those are ongoing uh and
what we're looking at and how uh what we
would like to remind the public of is
why we are at this point now um most
importantly none of the things we're
looking at now uh iran's increased
capability and capacity uh their
aggressive actions that they have taken
through proxy wars around the world
would be happening if the former
president had not recklessly pulled out
of the nuclear deal with no thought as
to why what might come next and if you
look at that step and the impact of that
uh the fact that the former president
ripped at the nuclear deal uh meant that
iran's nuclear program was no longer in
a box and no longer had the most robust
inspection regime ever negotiated no
longer had the tight restrictions on
nuclear activity and so now where we're
at even as these negotiations are
ongoing and as we conveyed back in
december uh
that we were a bit frustrated by the
lack of seriousness that negotiators
came to the table they've come back and
now we're back at the table again as i
noted but because of the last
administration pulling out of the
nuclear agreement uh now iran's program
has been rapidly accelerating iran
directly attacked our partners in the
gulf and its proxies began attacking u.s
troops again in iraq and the united
states has become totally had become
totally isolated internationally so uh
what we've been working to do is rebuild
those relationships our partnerships
with countries around the world get back
to the table so we can have that
increased capacity and ability to see
what is happening uh with the program uh
but right now the negotiations are
ongoing uh and we're of course eager to
see the diplomatic path move forward on
voting rights um you know you guys have
talked about yesterday's speech and and
the president's actions this week is him
showing that he's putting his whole
presidency behind this issue but if it
doesn't pass next week what does that
say about his presidency and his
political clout and what would you say
to democratic base voters who have seen
you know potentially not just one uh
legislative failure with buildback
better which has been shelved but
potentially a second legislative failure
in a month how do you convince
democratic voters to vote for you
what i think we would say to um
any american whether they're
based voters or not is that the majority
of the american public elected the
president to do hard things and to fight
for hard things including uh fighting
for issues that may feel like an uphill
battle but that are vitally important to
protecting fundamental rights of the
american public every single major
legislative effort
that the president has undertaken
that that he's been a part of has been
subject to all manner of speculation and
criticism about whether it would happen
or not
and if the president paid attention to
that he probably wouldn't want run for
president to begin with so uh his view
uh and i think the view of many uh in
the senate and many americans including
the activists you referenced is that uh
it is time to fight uh that uh that
protecting people's fundamental rights
this is a defining moment that will
divide everything before and everything
after when the most fundamental american
right that all others flow from the
right to vote and have your vote counted
uh is at risk uh and he is going to be
working the phones the vice president
will be working the phones as you know
he's heading up to the hill uh tomorrow
to speak to the caucus uh and make the
strong case that you heard him make
publicly directly to members uh tomorrow
uh and you know i think that's evidence
that he's to fight even when it's hard
go ahead mike um if i could ask just two
questions on uh covet testing so about
three weeks ago you and i had an
exchange in this room in which i in
which i made it sound nefarious i don't
remember it that way
but i i posited a bunch of questions
that you couldn't answer
um about when the tests would be
available how many americans would be
able to
order uh per family
you know when they would be rolling off
uh you know
actually looking at the factory floors
but then delivered to people and in
their hands
it's now three three and a half weeks
later um is there any are there any
answers to any of those questions yet
well i would say first we've put out a
number of steps that have been taken
since that point in time
the pleasant and democratic exchange we
had in this briefing room a few weeks
ago mike but uh including a number of
contracts have been signed there was an
rfp request for a proposal that was put
out it was important for us to take the
time to assess uh cl and work closely
with manufacturers and distributors to
understand what they can ship and by
when of course it's vitally important
this website goes up and people are
ordering it that they actually get what
they order right so that's what we've
been working on so a number of those
contracts have been signed uh we uh
expect uh that um the first um of
delivery of these contracts will be
arriving by early next week which is a
good sign we expect to also have details
or everyone can expect we'll have
details that we put out on the website
as well as a hotline later this week
more specifics about exactly the
questions that you've been asking so the
american public can expect that later
this week and we also expect to have all
contracts awarded for the 500 million
over the course of the next two weeks so
that's the status of where things stand
i would also note that um in that period
of time we've also been distributing 50
million
tests to community health centers and
rural health centers we've also expanded
our federal testing capacity including
right here in washington dc in new york
philadelphia new jersey other places
that have been impacted we made an
announcement about providing additional
funding and testing capacity to schools
today and tomorrow the president will be
providing an update on kovid and on our
ongoing effort uh to fight the virus and
providing an update on more we're going
to continue to do so that's what we can
expect but i would say we've made a
great deal of progress in the last few
weeks
to follow up on that
fair to say that that you know with half
of january finished and the first of the
of the doses the first of the doses
beginning to arrive maybe by next week
that there's no way that 500 million
tests are not doses tests are going to
be delivered and in the hands of
americans by the end of this month well
that's why we said at the time that that
we would begin to get these uh these
tests and they would begin to go out to
the american public in january and
that's we're exactly on track for that
and then the second question it goes
back to the summer one of the things you
guys have said repeatedly is that um the
reason that we don't that we're having
you're having to take the kind of steps
that you just talked about is because
there wasn't the capacity in the system
to produce the tests
uh so that they would be more available
now
um back in the summer when demand for
tests dropped off because
americans were more interested in
getting vaccinated and the cdc was
saying hey if you're vaccinated you
don't need to test and so i think
understandably demand dropped off
why didn't the administration
do what the federal government does in
many emergency
anthrax vaccines and others which is to
create a government market for tests and
say to test makers in may and june of
the of last year
we will guarantee that we'll buy a
billion a billion test kits
keep keep manufacturing them don't don't
stop why did the administration do that
in the summer so that we would have been
in a position
uh this fall when when when omicron hit
to have the number of tests and you
wouldn't have had to go through this
process well well i would say there were
steps that and decisions that were made
in the summer uh including um steps that
we took in the early fall uh which were
to use uh the defense production act to
uh three billion dollars worth to invest
in the testing market we expanded as a
in part as a result the testing capacity
by four times we quadrupled the size of
it and we also took a number of steps uh
through that period to expand the number
of tests that were on the market
obviously the fda works on their own
process but now there are nine tests
there are far fewer about half of that
number back in the summer so there were
a number of steps that were taken over
the course of time not just in december
not post omicron to expand and build the
testing capacity
okay karen thanks john you mentioned
that tomorrow the president is going to
give an update on the covet effort
can you give us any more details on that
is there going to be a major
announcement uh what will he be talking
about tomorrow well as you know karen at
every step in this process and and
frequently the president provides
updates on how we're building on our
capacity right whether that is vaccine
distribution or capacity at one point
testing capacity of supplies ppe so he
will be building on that uh tomorrow i
don't have anything specific to preview
preview for you in terms of the
components at this point but let me just
give you a sense of kind of what we've
been doing uh to address what we've seen
straining hospital capacity and needs as
we've seen uh the surge in omicron in
recent weeks uh to date and he'll talk
more about this tomorrow and build on it
is my point here so we have helped more
than 38 states and territories and
deployed over 2100 federal personnel and
thousands of ventilators ambulances and
other critical supplies in addition more
than 13 000 national guard members have
been activated in 48 states to support
vaccination testing and clinical care
these deployments are fully paid for of
course by the federal government
hundreds of military doctors and nurses
are already on the ground in new york
new hampshire vermont pennsylvania
indiana michigan wisconsin minnesota
missouri arizona new mexico with more to
follow and we're building on that and
this is all in addition to the hundreds
of fema and hhs clinical staff we've
also shipped nearly 5.5 million pieces
of ppe from hospital gowns to n95s to
gloves in the last two weeks alone and
we've also invited our fema
administrator come and give you guys an
update hopefully we'll be able to do
that by the end of the week but
point is we've been deploying a number
of federal resources and the president
will talk more about specifics and more
steps to build on that tomorrow
and one quick one on testing uh last
year the administration had announced
there would be 10 billion going to
schools for testing today well the
president last week specifically brought
up that 10 billion dollars when you made
a pretty forceful statement about
keeping schools open today the
administration announced 10 million
tests per month will be going to schools
what's the accounting for the 10 billion
dollars did schools use that is that
money gone and that's why there's now a
need for these additional tests to be
sent out directly
well the funding and money went to
states to distribute to local school
districts
that's how it essentially functioned i
think what the announcement today i'm
happy to check on the specifics of the
status of it for you what the
announcement today um uh it reflects is
our desire and our commitment to keep
schools open and do everything we need
to do to help keep schools open from the
federal government now a number of
schools in nearly every state across the
country has made arrangements with
testing providers to provide schools
with tests using that 10 billion dollars
in funds that you referenced but it's
been used in different ways from school
district to school district and so this
is just a reflection which has been
consistent with how we've approached our
uh our efforts uh uh to uh against the
pandemic to build on what we know works
and uh and a reflection of our
commitment to help school districts uh
stay open
go ahead
hi jen uh two questions for you uh first
of all i wanted to follow up on the
president's visit to georgia yesterday
yeah that's one of our markets where
voter restriction bills have passed and
been signed into law in the past year
the brennan center for justice says
nearly 100 more bills are pending this
year in state houses across the country
does the president feel powerless right
now to stop more voter restriction bills
from passing at the state and local
level
well i think we have to take the
president believes we have to take a
multi-faceted approach and know he
certainly does not feel powerless but he
thinks that one of the most effective
roles he can play now is by advocating
for congress
to pass two pieces of voting rights
legislation that will help protect put
in place a baseline of protections for
states across the country so there is
that not that inconsistency and of
course as you know georgia's one of the
states 19 states across the country have
already passed laws that are putting in
place additional restrictions to make it
harder to vote more to come that's why
it's so important to move forward with
legislation on the federal level my
question is on climate
last month we went to new orleans they
had a very large climate conference
there are thousands of researchers and
scientists and when we were there we met
a homeowner he lost his house to
hurricane ida his grandmother lost her
house to hurricane katrina he blames
climate change he wants action now today
the white house uh announced a host of
clean energy measures but as the
washington post reported on sunday
nearly three dozen rules that would
impact the environment
at the energy department are delayed
the president's climate plan is stuck in
the senate at the moment
so does the president
have a sense of urgency about climate
and if so
how is it not just important to the
president but urgent
well i would say that um the president
is eager to get uh climate legislation
passed and there's an enormous historic
largest ever investment in addressing
the climate crisis in his build back
better agenda and plan of course he
wants to get that across the finish line
but he's not waiting uh for congress to
act that is why he has taken steps to
tackle super pollutants phasing down
hfcs rallied the world on methane in
glasgow stood with auto workers and
america's big car manufacturers to roll
up plans to boost electric vehicles put
america on track to ensure that one of
every two cars sold will be zero
emissions within the decade uh he's
going to take continue to take steps
he's taken a number of steps that are
that he has the ability to take um to
address the climate to uh to adjust the
climate crisis and of course he wants to
get his legislation across the finish
line i think the point you raised is a
really interesting one i mean there is a
startling statistic that something like
one in three americans is impacted by
extreme weather across the country you
reference a specific storm there are
storms that have taken place in the
northeast and the northwest it's
devastating people's homes people's
communities and it's certainly and it's
also a devastating local economies and
it's a reminder of why it's so important
to act on this on climate the president
believes it's urgent
absolutely
go ahead in the back
thanks um on uh buildback better
there was a lot of discussion about
whether it would help or hurt the
situation on inflation uh just notice in
the inflation statement from the white
house this morning there was no
reference to buildback better there was
a reference to the american rescue plan
i was wondering if that reflects
anything about the view of the white
house on the prospects for buildback
better or the role can play
in the situation on inflation no i i
would say that um that the uh your
colleagues here who are frequent this
briefing room have heard us say more
times than they can probably count uh
the role of uh of a number of uh
economists in advocating for build back
better passing because of the impact it
would have on lowering costs and and
addressing inflation and ultimately how
the american people experience inflation
as we were talking about when brian
diese was here is cost rising whether
it's the cost of meat or which of course
we say has a range of
range of reasons for it uh or the cost
of goods they're purchasing and for us
our objective and focus on lowering
costs and the biggest cost some of the
biggest costs impacting the public are
child care health care
elder care issues that are addressed and
build back better
covet in the briefing this morning jeff
said you're in the process of quote
strongly considering options to make
more high quality masks available to all
americans but i don't think they really
got into specifics on that can you share
in any of the options options that you
guys are looking at i don't have more
details i would just echo what jeff said
is that we are strongly considering that
and certainly want to uh ensure that
everybody has the uh necessary
protections as we continue to fight the
virus
go ahead let's see go ahead jonathan
thank you three years ago a new jersey
college student was murdered after
getting into a fake uber legislation to
require ride-hailing services like uber
and lyft
uh to have electronic systems to match
riders with passengers is awaiting white
house sign off this year would you stand
on the legislation and would the
president be willing to meet with the
parents of the murdered woman as they
requested
well i think you're referring to sami's
law and i remember that story well i
don't know anybody who saw it or read it
who wasn't um deeply impacted by it uh
we are committed uh to ensuring that the
safety the safety of all passengers
including those in rideshare and will
work closely with congress to ensure
federal oversight of rideshare companies
to protect other parents from the
tragedy of sami's parents have uh have
gone through and her friends and her
entire community we've met members of
the administration have met with her
family and continue to be in touch on
this important issue we thank them for
their continued advocacy in terms of a
meeting with the president i just don't
have anything to preview at this point
in time and one other question
transportation departments accelerating
a pilot program to allow truck drivers
under age 21 to drive across state lines
which safety advocates say could hurt
truck safety at a time where deaths and
truck crashes are up more than a third
over the last decade why is the
administration
prioritizing that issue over other
safety measures such as emergency
braking speed control devices which
national transportation national
transportation board has among its most
wanted safety improvements we're
certainly very mindful of safety the
reason this was included in the
bipartisan infrastructure act is because
we need to address the shortage of
drivers which is impacting of course the
transferring of goods and then the cost
of goods on the shelves right so uh but
we are approaching this and ensuring
it's implemented in a way that sets a
high bar for safety and quality
registered apprenticeships offers
critical structural critical structure
on this front which includes ensuring
that training programs are held to
define standards and include significant
supervised and paid on-the-job training
including with skilled driving mentors
and all pilot participants in this
program have to be trained on trucks
equipped with cameras automated
automatic emergency brakes and speed
limiters and we want to make sure it's
as safe as possible while also
addressing the need to have more drivers
so that we can move more goods and lower
the cost for americans across the
country did i get to everyone so far oh
go ahead
oh no go ahead go ahead um
thanks for the question um
yesterday during his speech in georgia
president biden only very briefly
mentioned the provisions of the let
america vote act that deal with
gerrymandering and getting money out of
politics
uh those provisions actually pull better
in public polling frequently than sort
of the broader stuff about protecting
the right to vote um throughout this
process but has been very focused the
president on those right to vote
provisions why hasn't he talked more
about those gerrymandering provisions
about the revisions about getting money
out of politics which do seem to be
quite popular
i would say first what the president's
objective was going into the the speech
yesterday was to make very clear to the
american public what was at stake and
exactly what it means when we say uh
your vote is being suppressed across the
country because sometimes we or this is
what's on his mind i should say we
shorthand and we talk about legislation
or the status or the meeting with this
person or that person and the american
people's their eyes glaze over because
they don't that doesn't mean anything to
them so the objective uh in the speech
yesterday for him was to really spend
the majority of time uh talking about
what the impact was why this was such a
dire issue and what was at stake and why
it was important to potentially make
changes to uh to uh to senate uh rules
in order to get this legislation passed
so i wouldn't overread into how many
words he spent on different pieces of
legislation he cares deeply about both
of these pieces of legislation he wants
to sign them into law
and then yeah go ahead uh senator rami
today basically said i'll use the exact
quote that the speech yesterday that the
president gave was quote going down the
same traffic rotate by president trump
and casting the doubt on the reliability
of american elections does the white
house ever respond to that
with all due respect to to senator
romney i think anyone would note there's
a night and day difference between
fermenting and insurrection based on
lies totally debunked by 80 judges
including trump appointed ones and
election authorities across the country
and making objective true statements
which is what the president made
yesterday about the effects of a
coordinated nationwide effort to
undermine the constitutional right to
vote i know there has been a lot of
claim of the offensive nature of the
speech yesterday which is
hilarious on many levels given how many
people sat silently over the last four
years for the former president but i
would note that in our view and the
president's view what is far more
offensive is the effort to suppress
people's basic right to exercise who
they want to support and who they want
to elect that's not a partisan thing uh
and that uh that was why he gave such a
strong speech yesterday go ahead follow
up on the issue of mass and this push to
expand access to high quality mass
health experts that have long been
urging and calling for americans to
upgrade their mass so
why wait until now to push for this
wider availability of better mass what's
taken so long so just to to be clear
there is no shortage of masks on the
market that that is not an issue i know
that my colleagues from the cova team uh
made clear that we have a strong
stockpile over 750 million mass
that we have at our disposal uh widely
available n95 masks other masks uh what
the cdc director conveyed is that
they're going they're in the process of
updating
information on their website to help
address and answer these questions their
guidance currently is a well-fitted mask
but what we're trying to do is continue
to be responsive to what people's needs
are across the country and make sure
they're getting the supplies where we
need them but there's no shortage there
is a a wide uh 750 million uh masks uh
that we have available
to mitch mcconnell today who uh had some
strong words for the president called
his speech a rant incoherent profoundly
unpresidential but he also keeps the
president of shouting that 52 senators
and millions of americans are racist
unless he gets what he whatever he wants
well i know the president was asked
about this and said a version of this i
should say and he said uh he considers
uh mitch mcconnell a friend and and that
is true
that is why is it even more
disappointing that someone who has
supported and advocated for voting
rights uh in the past wrote about in his
book has talked about it publicly and
repeatedly voted for the extension of
voting rights protections uh is on the
other side of this argument now um you
know and i i think clearly struck a
nerve the president's speech yesterday
and the vice president's remarks i think
there's evidence of that but to us and
to the president what is more
irresponsible unbecoming and divisive is
the coordinated effort by far too many
republicans across the country to
perpetuate the big lie and make it more
difficult to vote and we are seeing
evidence of that in 19 states who passed
which passed 34 laws attacking voting
rights that's why he's standing up and
made the passionate case he made
yesterday
okay
all right thanks
go ahead
yesterday happy to talk about facebook
anytime
i guess
sorry a district judge yesterday denied
the company's motion to dismiss the
fgc's report of a revised any trust
complaint essentially clearing the way
for it to go
forward i'm wondering whether you have a
view on that and in particular that case
is seeking to essentially break up the
company to split off instagram and
whatsapp is that something the white
house things should have
well uh we welcome the district court's
decision which allows the federal trade
commission's anti-trust lawsuit against
facebook to move forward the favorable
decision is a testament to the skill and
determination of the federal trade
commission staff and its experts for
generations the americans approach has
been to expose
american approach has been to expose our
main tech firms to more competition the
president supports that he's talked
about that publicly a number of times
that approach has been key to our
innovation and success and we've been
clear and he's been clear we need more
competition in the tech industry as you
know there are a range of pieces of
legislation bipartisan many of them in
congress that's encouraging uh and in
july of course the president signed an
executive order on competition which
among several actions called on the
federal agencies like the department of
justice and the fdc to use existing
tools to tackle these problems so we're
not going to prejudge what it looks like
of course there's a legal case here that
legal case will be moving forward but
certainly we're encouraged by the
district court's decision thanks
everyone
um
oh
oh
you